willkommen zufolge 205 des faz einspruch
podcast heute am mittwoch den sechsten
april 20 22 ich begrüße sie sehr
herzlich aus berlin mein name ist helene
bobrowski politik korrespondent in der
faz und an meiner seite heute
verlor ins freie journalistin und
juristin aus köln 9 schön dass du dabei
bist ja wir haben heute ein sehr sehr
sehr volles programm
es ist auch einfach sehr sehr viel los
es ist viel los und leider muss ich
schon vorab sagen wenig erfreulich jetzt
kann man wohl so sagen wir fangen
natürlich an mit den grauenvollen
verbrechen in butter also wie immer mit
dem angriffskrieg auf die ukraine und
machen dann weiter mit einem schwerpunkt
interview mit isabella genau eine
völkerrechtlerin die am mpi heidelberg
tätig ist und mit mir spricht über das
strategie defizit in der deutschen
außen- und sicherheitspolitik also eine
reine frage die sehr theoretisch erst
mal klingt aber durchaus praktische
auswirkungen hat und einiges von dem
erklärt was wir in den vergangenen
jahren gesehen haben dann haben wir
einen corona blog denn die ampel macht
ja wieder diese woche einen ziemlich
chaotischen eindruck einerseits geht es
um die allgemeine impfpflicht die am
morgigen donnerstag nun entschieden
werden soll und niemand weiß wie das
ausgeht dann gibt es einen rollback in
sachen quarantäne beziehungsweise
isolation für infizierte von karl
lauterbach gestern abend im fernsehen
und die frage ist was gilt nun
eigentlich in welchem bundesland wo muss
ich mal ausgetragen und wo nicht hamburg
und mecklenburg vorpommern haben sich
zur hot spot ländern erklärt dazu ein
paar kurze rechtliche setzte außerdem
hat es heute morgen bezeichnen auf am
mittwoch um 11 bundesweite
durchsuchungen gegen neonazis gegeben
ich habe mit dem kollegen markus jung
über den prozess gegen den minister
comex wie man ihn gerne nennt hanno
berger gesprochen der in dieser woche
vor dem landgericht bonn begonnen und
natürlich kam gestern noch mal der
europäische gerichtshof mit der
vorratsdatenspeicherung in einem fall
aus irland der allerdings durchaus ein
paar hinweise für eine mögliche deutsche
neuregelung enthält so sieht's aus dann
haben wir noch was europäisches nämlich
dass rechtsstaats verfahren gegen ungarn
und wir haben noch ein gerechtes urteil
das ist vielleicht das lustigste an
dieser sendung es geht immerhin um so
oktoberfest genau was das zumindest das
einzig wirklich leichter in dieser
sendung
[Musik]
gut dann fangen wir direkt an mit den
schrecklichen verbrechen von butscher
dort haben wahrscheinlich alle
mittlerweile diese furchtbaren bilder
gesehen nach dem rückzug der russischen
truppen aus dem vorort von kiew da
liegen leichen auf den strassen also
zivilistinnen und zivilisten zum teil
mit den händen auf dem rücken gefesselt
es gibt mittlerweile zunehmend mehr
grauenvolle berichte von augenzeugen und
augenzeuginnen über verschleppte
zivilisten über hingerichtete menschen
russland behauptet das seien alles fake
news von ukrainischer seite und jetzt
werden dort beweise gesammelt die eu und
die un haben unterstützung angekündigt
forensiker innen sind vor ort und suchen
nach juristisch verwertbaren material
wofür denn eigentlich will ich genau es
geht natürlich darum irgendwann
hoffentlich wladimir putin der dafür
verantwortlich zeichnet vor den
internationalen strafgerichtshof zu
bringen und ihn dort anzuklagen wegen
kriegsverbrechen parallel gibt es ja
noch ein verfahren das schon begonnen
wurde gegen russland als staat vor dem
internationalen gerichtshof wegen des
angriffskriegs aber konkret was jetzt
die forensiker dort suchen das sind auch
journalisten im einsatz auch ein kollege
von uns ist derzeit in butter und es
gibt satellitenaufnahmen jetzt
amerikanische journalistin aus werden
weil es tatsächlich total wichtig ist
ganz genau hinzuschauen was ist wo
passiert also die leichen müssen so
schrecklich das ist ganz genau
fotografiert werden bevor sie an einen
anderen ort verschafft werden und ganz
genau nachzuweisen was die russen dort
wann gemacht haben weil nämlich das was
wir jetzt im un-sicherheitsrat gesehen
haben also der russische botschafter der
tatsächlich davon spricht dass es eine
inszenierte provokation der ukraine sei
das wären die natürlich auch in späteren
gerichtsverfahren
vortragen und da muss es wirklich recht
sichere beweise dafür geben dass das die
russen waren und dann ist natürlich auch
noch die sag ich mal tücken des
humanitären völkerrechts die station
schiffen gilt denn das ist
wahrscheinlich vielen hörern und hörern
klar eigentlich im grundsatz gilt
kampfhandlung dürfen sich eigentlich nur
den kombattanten richten aber doch
eigentlich gegen soldatinnen und
soldaten richtig gehen da oder eben
gegen was es ja in der ukraine jetzt
auch gibt sozusagen so freiwillige
kampfverbände oder ähnliches die nicht
zur staatlichen armee gehören aber
dennoch im kampf aktiv sind jetzt ist es
aber ebenso dass nicht jede aktion gegen
einen zivilisten automatisch ein
kriegsverbrechen ist sondern es gibt den
sogenannten
kollateralschaden also wenn ein zivilist
ich zum beispiel jetzt vor einer
militärischen einrichtung aufhält und so
zu schaden kommt weil russland einen
angriff auf eine militärische
einrichtung verübt dann ist das noch
kein kriegsverbrechen auch wenn es von
zivilisten selber
feindselige handlung ausgehen also wenn
sie etwa selber schießen oder anderes so
arbeite das ist so weiß man jetzt und so
kann man auf diesen bildern natürlich
sehr klar erkennen in butscher nicht der
fall du hast es gesagt die menschen
liegen mit den händen gefesselt mit dem
gesicht zum boden auf dem rücken die
hände sind nach hinten gebunden da ist
es unmöglich sich ja selber feindselig
verhalten zu haben es sei denn so wie
die russen behaupten dass hatten später
die ukraine so arrangiert und genau um
diese fragen wird es später gehen und
deswegen ist diese ganz genaue
dokumentation so wichtig bevor die
leichen beerdigt werden und das machen
jetzt wenn menschen was sicherlich eine
sehr schwere arbeit ist um eben ganz
genau dass festzuhalten die rede ist ja
von hinrichtung allein in butter soll es
das ist alles noch nicht bestätigt aber
über 400 tote zivilisten gegeben haben
und insgesamt sagen sprechen die ukraine
von 7.000 meldungen über
kriegsverbrechen mittlerweile in der
ukraine
wir bleiben da dran auch natürlich es
wird uns noch jahre begleiten die
rechtliche aufarbeitung dieser
verbrechen
[Musik]
und jetzt begrüße ich sehr herzlich in
der leitung isabella die
völkerrechtlerin habilitanden am max
planck institut für ausländisches
öffentliches recht und völkerrecht in
heidelberg hallo frau lyla
und frei hat auf dem verfassungs blog
eine neue serie gestartet vor kurzem
über die sogenannte zeitenwende und
darüber wollen wir heute sprechen was
ist eigentlich die zeitenwende was hat
sie verändert insbesondere in der frage
der
strategischen debatten in deutschland
zu krieg und frieden um es mal so zu
sagen verleiht die serie auf dem
verfassungs blog heißt
sicherheitsstrategie nach der
zeitenwende institutionen recht und
politik ich fange mal mit einer ganz
allgemeinen frage an ist denn das was
wir am 27
februar gesehen haben also die rede von
olaf scholz im bundestag ist es
überhaupt eine echte zeitenwende in der
deutschen außen- und sicherheitspolitik
entscheidung getroffen aber ich bin eben
versuchen wir auch mit dieser block
debatte jetzt zu befördern das ist eben
darüber hinaus eine umfassende analyse
und auch debatte dieser themen auch die
frage stellt ganz ganz im sinne einer
umfassenden sicherheitsstrategie was
sind die szenarien risiken auf die wir
uns einstellen wollen welche
themenbereiche sind davon betroffen
welche ansätze erscheinen uns überzeugen
um darauf zu reagieren mit welchen
sicherheitspolitischen partnern auch und
welche mittel wollen wir eben jetzt
anwenden um diese ziele zu erreichen und
in der rede vom 27 runden bestimmte
mittel jetzt anvisiert aber ich finde
diese ganze anderen lösung dieser
debatte darüber die erfordert die
beginnt ja gerade erst in den abfahrten
was debatte jetzt eben bringt diese
länder auch sein
also die mittel darüber haben wir hier
auch schon mehrfach gesprochen dass es
das ist sondervermögen von 100
milliarden euro das sind
waffenlieferungen kriegsgebiete was
vorher nicht der deutschen politik
entsprach und andere elemente unter
anderem die übererfüllung des 2 prozent
ziels sie sprechen aber jetzt über was
anderes nämlich dass diese bisherige
kultur der strategischen zurückhaltung
durchbrochen wurde so haben sie es auch
in ihrem beitrag formuliert woran lag
denn eigentlich diese strategische
zurückhaltung oder dieses ja diese diese
ist es eine unfähigkeit oder eine
unwilligkeit sich mit diesen
strategischen fragen zu beschäftigen
[Musik]
militärische missionen der nato zum
beispiel und der westlichen partner
teilgenommen hat und dann eher mit
untergeordneten beiträgen das ist das
eine was zum beispiel
teilgenommen irak-krieg und den einsatz
das andere ist aber ab einem engeren
sinne einer strategische zurückhaltung
im sinne eines ich würde es so
formulieren eine strategie defizit eines
defizits im nachdenken und im
analysieren letztlich unserer außen- und
politischen situation der positionierung
deutschlands als außenpolitischer player
in der welt und
formulieren und können sie sagen was
woran das gelegen hat ist diese
pazifistische grundstimmung in
deutschland insgesamt so stark dass es
eigentlich eine unwilligkeit gibt sich
mit solchen szenarien ernsthaft
auseinanderzusetzen
gerade in ihrer frage schon angesprochen
einerseits hat natürlich die deutsche
gesellschaft das ist ja ihr habt mal was
gutes würde ich sagen und was total
schlüssiges und nachvollziehbares und
wahrscheinlich historische notwendiges
gewesen natürlich den prozess einer ganz
extremen demilitarisierung durchlaufen
nach dem zweiten weltkrieg aber vor
allem auch noch mal in den letzten zehn
jahren vielleicht nach der abschaffung
der allgemeinen wehrpflicht also wir
sind einfach gar nicht mehr gewöhnt
ja eine militärische antwort
militärische kategorien oder auch
geopolitische kategorien haben anders
als viele andere westliche
gesellschaften wo das irgendwie mehr im
alltag sage ich meine rolle spielt und
greifbar ist und eine naheliegende
lösung auch für konflikte unter
umständen ja und natürlich haben die
alliierten großbritannien frankreich usa
einen anderen schluss auf dem zweiten
weltkrieg gezogen nämlich gerade nicht
wie wir frieden schaffen ohne waffen
sondern möglicherweise ist es das
falsche man muss vielleicht manchmal zu
den waffen greifen um die falschen
händen das ist das eine diese die
militarisierung die die
gesellschaftlichen aufnahm und die dazu
führt dass er gar nicht militärischen
kategorien zu denken gewohnt sind und
natürlich auch militärische analysen
sich deswegen in der öffentlichen
debatte nicht irgendwie durchsetzen
nicht unbedingt gehör finden dann die
dabei und damit zusammenhängend was sie
angesprochen haben der weit verbreitete
pazifismus in unserer gesellschaft der
natürlich auch eine folge des zweiten
weltkriegs ist und willy brandts
ostpolitik und weiter die ursprünge
proteste gegen den nato doppelbeschluss
unsere reise sehr weit verbreitet ist
immer noch bis heute teilen der linken
der grünen der spd der bevölkerung ich
würde sogar sagen bis hinein in eine
community die völkerrechts community in
deutschland eben auch diese
grundintention erstmal mitbringt
tierische lösung wirklich der richtige
weg um konflikte zu lösen
das hat man ja auch übrigens am
demonstrationsgeschehen gesehen hier in
berlin was ja immer als
friedensdemonstration gedacht wenn man
soll ja auch diese peace-zeichen und so
weiter auf diesen demonstrationen was
ihr den einen oder anderen ukraine auch
irritiert hat genauso wie jetzt
friedenskonzert in bellevue oder so wo
die ukraine sagen moment mal wir führen
gerade einen krieg und jetzt geht es
darum den krieg zu gewinnen und nicht
hier für pazifismus einzutreten
dort und auch den
unterschied natürlich
jetzt ganz klar an der tagesordnung dass
man sich zur wehr setzt und auch mit
waffen und sie haben nicht den impuls
wir stellen uns ihnen jetzt ohne waffen
entgegen sie sollten sie auf diesen tag
haben sich auch nicht mehr ohne waffen
entgegen gestellt jetzt mit waffen führt
das jetzt so schrecklich
das ist er absolut nachvollziehbar
insofern genau ich also ich hab das auch
beobachtet am 27 februar da gab es in
berlin das ist schon ein bisschen
untergegangen in der berichterstattung
zwei demonstrationen die eine große über
die viel gerichtet wurde wo die fotos
auch in allen medien gelaufen sind an
der straße des 17 juni da am großen
stern das war so ein konglomerat also
das waren dieses ist diese demo ist
gefolgt auf einen aufruf eines
konglomerat von ich sag mal
friedensbewegten organisation die aber
auch sehr verankert sind in der
deutschen gesellschaft wer die
evangelische kirche auch ökologische
gruppierungen die linke war dabei und so
weiter und so fort und sie haben auch in
dem aufruf und das war wohl auch
sichtbar auf transparenten und in den
reden einen engen zusammenhang
hergestellt zwischen
friedenspolitischen ansinnen und
ökologischen und sozial politischen
zielsetzungen und andererseits gab sich
noch plakativ auf der anderen seite des
brandenburger tors
auf der östlichen seite
eine demonstration die vom
alexanderplatz losging und ich dann
russischen botschaft unter den bewegt
hat die war einem aufruf gefolgt einer
ukrainischen endlich audi in berlin
tätig ist also ich hab ich das richtig
aussprechen ich glaube dass glaube
ukraine berlin ich weiß gar nicht ob es
ganz genau richtig im kopf habe den
namen wie sehen sie aus und da waren und
da auf der demonstration war ich weil
ich eine ukrainische freundin habe die
mir den aufruf dazu geschickt verteilt
bezeichnenderweise gab es auch im
vorhinein der üppigen durcheinander mir
war ist ganz klar ob das die eine oder
die andere soaps freigibt das hat sie
mir dann klar gestellt und die war nicht
so multipel sage ich mal in den
ansetzungen
da gab es überhaupt nicht da war das
thema eben allein der ukraine krieg und
die forderungen waren
wesentlich weniger friedenspolitisch
ausgerichtet nach mehr waffen und dabei
erst am abend bevor überhaupt die
entscheidung deutschlands der
bundesregierung gefallen dass wir nun
doch waffen liefern wollen nachdem
hermann i fand ich diesen gebieten
klammer auf was ja auch nicht so ganz zu
treffen dass wenn man sich die
vergangenheit anklamer zu also mehr
waffen dann wurde aufgefordert eine
flugverbotszone über der ukraine zu
richten also es war eigentlich rein
militär politische zielsetzungen die von
dieser demonstration erfolgte war
wesentlich kleiner und hat nicht so viel
medien-echo erworben aber daran kann man
diese zweiteilung vielleicht auch ganz
gut sichtbar machen und würde sagen
diese zeitenwende geht in richtung
ukrainische demonstration aber der rest
der großteil der demonstrierenden an dem
tag hat auf der anderen dem primo
demonstriert und die müssen natürlich
irgendwie mitgenommen oder da muss man
auch eine diskursive verbindung
hergestellt werden die aufgabe kinder
und es gibt ja den einen teil nehmen sie
jetzt beschrieben haben die ökologisch
motivierten auch linken gruppierungen
die sich dem pazifismus zuordnen aber in
deutschland die konservativen tun sich
schwer damit weil sie jetzt seit 16
jahren natürlich regiert haben und diese
politik einer ja zumindest in einem sehr
engen wirtschaftlichen austausch mit
russland
stichwort 92 und ähnliches natürlich
auch mitgetragen haben das macht es auf
allen seiten des politischen spektrums
natürlich schwierig da jetzt eine neue
verordnung vorzunehmen ich wollte noch
mit ihnen sprechen über die im engeren
sinne rechtlichen fragen die damit
zusammenhängen mit dieser sogenannten
strategischen
zurückhaltung gibt es also was ja auch
sie haben es beschrieben als ja auch
sozusagen institutionelles defizit dass
es auch in den betroffenen ressorts zum
beispiel aber auch im bundestag diese
strategische debatte die sie fordern
also die debatte über eine über die
ausrichtung deutschlands in dieser frage
eine offene debatte die möglichst viele
menschen einschließt also faktoren die
diese debatte beschweren können sie uns
noch mal sagen worin sie das welche
faktoren das sind und was sich da ändern
muss
leben gerufen wurde es gab das weißbuch
des
bundesverteidigungsministeriums von 2016
es gab einer debatte um die anschaffung
von kampfdrohnen in der letzten und
vorletzten registratur und es gibt ein
weißbuch multilateralismus des
auswärtigen amts von 2021
aber ich würde sagen also diese prozesse
und papiere da die wurden durchaus auch
mit dem anliegen geführt da ich sag mal
nicht nur die bundesregierung sozusagen
zu involvieren sondern auch weitere
teile der interessierten öffentlichkeit
mit einzubeziehen aber es waren eben
gefälschte prozesse vom außenministerium
oder vom verteidigungsministerium in
geben ich sage meinen öffentlichkeit
involviert war aber eine breitere
öffentlichkeit und in debatte in die
gesellschaft hinein wo du vielleicht mit
ausnahme der kampf schon ein stück weit
oder nicht vielleicht war auch der
zeitpunkt dafür nicht der richtige ich
würde sagen jetzt ist es amtlich das ist
eine ganz breite aufmerksamkeit und
annalena baerbock sei dank hat sie ja
nun auch am 18 märz an einer auftakte
rede gehalten indem sie eine solche
debatte initiieren möchte mit dem ziel
dann eben einer nationale
sicherheitsstrategie vorzulegen was
wären die ampelkoalition sich auch im
koalitionsvertrag vorgenommen hatte
insofern sind wir in diesem prozess aber
in der tat wie sie ist auch schon
angesprochen haben ich würde sagen ganz
wichtig ist es eben noch mal zu fragen
was ist eigentlich der grund dafür dass
diese diese initiativen die da auch in
den letzten jahren schon erfolgt sind
nicht so richtig nachhaltig waren dass
da nicht eine dauerhafte debatte
entstanden die auch institutionelle nord
hatte und deswegen auf die richtigen
akteure involviert hat und die deswegen
auf möglicherweise in die bevölkerung
weiterhin eingereicht als der fall war
und da ist meine analyse eben dass es da
eben auch so eine art institutionelles
defizit an vor ort unsere strategie die
beiden gibt's in deutschland wenn man in
die bundesregierung fehlt ist an einer
vermittlung und das dann geht auch die
analyse von klaus naumann das ist nicht
alles auf meinem mist gewachsen
fehlt es an einer vermittlung von
militärischen sachverstand und außen und
sicherheitspolitischen ist eigentlich
die frage noch einmal wie gestaltet man
die schnittstelle von
verteidigungsministerium und
außenministerium es gibt den
bundessicherheitsrat der entscheidet im
geheimen auf allerhöchster ebene unter
involvierung der jeweiligen spitzen die
ministerin aber auch noch andere über
rüstungsexporte der hat sich thematisch
ganz engen entwickelt dann gibt es eben
das sicherheitskabinett dass sich ja
wohl auch getroffen hat in den letzten
wochen das sind noch mal weniger
mitglieder ich mit dem bundeskanzler
treffen die sind das wird aber immer nur
ad hoc zusammengerufen das ist nicht auf
dauer gestellt und trifft sicher nun
auch im geheim da weiß man dass nach
nennt vielleicht gibt es regierung aber
das ist keine öffentliche debatte aber
man könnte ja denken dass sie eine
parlamentsarmee haben also über jeden
einsatz über jedes mandat der bundestag
abstimmen muss könnte man ja denken der
ort für die debatte ist das parlament
aus diesem grund
[Musik]
das parlament eine der bundeswehr
autorisiert
kann da auch eine solche debatte nicht
so richtig stattfinden weil jedoch sehr
auf den einzelfall bezogen auf den
einzelnen einsatz die werden dann für
ein jahr autorisiert in einem ganz
bestimmten gebiet mit einer ganz
bestimmten truppenstärke und ganz
bestimmten fähigkeiten
gewisse ein einsatz interne ziele zu
erreichen aber es gibt eben auch da
keine debatte über diesen einzelfall
hinaus der sozusagen mal mit einer etwas
längerfristigen perspektive schaut wie
kommen wir aus dem einsatz wieder heraus
welche arten von einsätze wollen wir
eigentlich in zukunft führen mit dieser
bundeswehr denn diese frage stellt sich
nach dem scheitern des afghanistan
einsatzes
ganz besonders auch wieder im moment und
ihren umschwenken weg von out of area
einsätze wieder mehr zur verteidigung
des eigenen tweet oder das ruhrgebiet
noch mal um so dringlicher und dafür
scheint doch der parlamentsvorbehalt
indem er ihm nur einzelne
bundeswehreinsätzen mandatiert werden
nicht unbedingt geeignet
eine letzte frage was ja auch debattiert
werden muss sagen jedenfalls viele ist
die frage was ist eigentlich
sicherheit was es eigentlich
verteidigung was dann wieder zusammen
hängt mit den mitteln über die wir schon
sprachen nämlich zum beispiel die 100
milliarden euro also die frage hat mir
haben wir eigentlich einen weiten
sicherheitsbegriff wo etwa auch
zivilschutz und entwicklungshilfe und
alles mögliche darunter fällt was sich
die grünen gut vorstellen können oder
definiert man sicherheit eben doch sehr
eng auf das militärische gemünzt auf die
ausstattung der bundeswehr
wie sehen sie auf diese debatte muss ja
jetzt schon vorschläge gibt es das geht
das so in die richtige richtung und dann
stellt sich aber natürlich die frage wie
werden solche debatten am ende
eigentlich entschieden diese fragen
müssen ja irgendwann auch entschieden
werden
letzten jahren eher dahin geht sie
braucht neben erweiterten anders also
was ich denke was zentral ist und das
entspricht ich sag mal jedenfalls findet
vorsichtig erweiterten ansatz ist ja
dass man diese lektion irgendwie
intellektuell und analytisch verarbeiten
muss dass die annahme dass man
wirtschaft und politik wirtschaft und
außenpolitik wirtschaft und politik
komplett trennen kann oder weitgehend
rennen kann die sich ja auch dann
widergespiegelt hat in der deutschen
politik 92 und nicht angesprochen aber
vielleicht auch sogar in der
europäischen und globalen handels
politik und institutionen die dazu
gehören diese liberale annahme und die
trennung von wirtschaft und politik das
jedoch stark hinterfragt werden muss wer
auch im moment sehen die jungen
genau wir sehen das mit blick auf
russland die große unbekannte
ja also große frage mit einer noch
offenen antwort ist ja die frage nach
china wo ja auch deutsche unternehmen
sagen jetzt das russland geschäft ist
auch wichtig aber wir denn wenn das
china-geschäft zusammenbricht dann
können wir den laden dicht machen und
wir haben das in der vergangenen
legislaturperiode diskutiert in sachen
5g also zur frage inwieweit machen wir
uns abhängig von den chinesen beim
aufbau unseres stil funkstandards all
diese fragen sagt jedenfalls so verstehe
ich sie frei müssen wir müssen jetzt
noch mal auf den tisch müssten neu
diskutiert werden die frage von schafen
verflechtung der der welt letztlich
wirtschaftliche verflechtung und zu
welchem preis muss das stattfinden also
ein aufruf zu mehr debatte in erster
linie von ihnen vielen dank für ihre
zeit
wir packen den verweis auf die serie im
verfassungs blog wer gerne in unsere
chance damit sich auch alle unsere
hörerinnen und hörer an dieser debatte
beteiligen können und werden weiter
verfolgen wie sich die sache gestaltet
dass dieses momentum der zeitenwende ja
vielleicht dann jedenfalls in dieser
hinsicht etwas gutes haben könnte
[Musik]
dann kommen wir zum nicht zu vermissen
corona block in dieser woche ist wieder
viel los und wie wir es im intro schon
gesagt haben es ist viel chaos los am
montag hieß es nach einem treffen der
gesundheitsministerin und minister der
länder gemeinsam mit karl lauterbach
relativ überraschend ab dem ersten mai
solle es keine quarantäne und keine
isolation mehr geben zumindest nur noch
eine freiwillige gestern abend ich
glaube bei markus lanz war ist hat karl
lauterbach das jetzt wieder zurück zu
genau und zwar konkret geht es um die
isolation es muss man immer
auseinanderhalten isolation betrifft
diejenigen die tatsächlich corona
positiv sind quarantäne sind die
kontakte von ihnen und er hat jetzt
gestern abend überraschend gesagt dass
er den vorschlag einkassieren werde weil
er findet dass er das ist eine
verheerende wirkung oder eine
verheerende aussage so sinngemäß ist das
corona eben doch nicht so gefährlich sei
wenn jetzt infizierte selber entscheiden
könnten ob sie auf die straße gehen ob
sie sich unter leute mischen oder nicht
sozusagen ein richtiger befund man fragt
sich nur warum kommt er erst so spät und
am abend im fernsehen auf die idee
wahrscheinlich für den pressesprecher
auch kein besonders schöner tag gewesen
gestern und heute kann man sich ungefähr
vorstellen er hat es so begründet dass
die gesundheitsämter ja darum gebeten
haben diese isolation nicht mehr
verpflichtend zu machen weil sie nicht
mehr hinterherkommen mit der information
mit der anordnung der isolation und so
weiter und das hört man ja auch aus dem
eigenen umfeld das die leute teilweise
dann post vom gesundheitsamt bekommen
wenn sie schon wieder aus der isolation
heraus sind schon wieder frei getestet
sind also da ist natürlich angesichts
dieser infektionszahlen auch nicht
verwunderlich auch ein ziemliches chaos
trotzdem gab es erst diese ankündigung
der freiwilligkeit das hat er jetzt
zurückgezogen das soll allerdings ist
hat er klargestellt nicht gelten für die
quarantäne also für kontaktpersonen die
sollen mir ab erster mai dann
tatsächlich selbst entscheiden können ob
sie in quarantäne gehen oder nicht wenn
momentan liegt die fraktionsvorsitzende
der linken hat schon darauf verwiesen
was das alles auch möglicherweise für
konsequenzen hat für leute in prekären
jobs die dann weil es freiwillig ist
möglicherweise eben dann zur arbeit
gehen ehrlich gesagt auch nicht nur in
prekären jobs da muss man sich schon
fragen wie wird das in unternehmen dann
umgesetzt so dass das zieht so viele
folge fragen nach sich ich glaube das
wird uns noch ein bisschen beschäftigt
absolut morgen hoffentlich ist ein im
schlusspunkt erstmal für die debatte um
die impfpflicht auch da geht es aber
überaus chaotisch zu das fing ja wenn
wir uns erinnern schon sehr chaotisch an
mit der impfpflicht weil die ampel im
dezember entschieden hatte keinen
regierungsantrag vorzulegen sondern in
so genannte gruppen verfahren ins
sogenannte gruppen verfahren zu gehen
also
fraktionsübergreifende anträge zur in
pflicht einzubringen und so war die
offizielle begründung weil es sich um
eine ethische frage handele und so hat
man es ja bei der organspende und bei
der sterbehilfe auch gemacht in wahrheit
und das kommt jetzt immer mehr ans
tageslicht wurde dann natürlich aus der
not eine tugend gemacht die not besteht
deshalb weil die fdp von anfang an bei
einer impfpflicht nicht mitgehen wollte
oder jedenfalls ganz große teile der fdp
so dass der ampel eine mehrheit fehlte
und sie dann versuchte eben über dieses
gruppen verfahrene mehrheit zu finden
das hat nicht funktioniert unter anderem
deshalb weil die union sich an den
gruppen verfahren nicht beteiligt hat
sondern einen eigenen antrag gemacht hat
als fraktion in dem sie ein im register
gefordert hat und ansonsten eine art ja
modus fordert wie man im herbst das
ganze monitor und wo zwar theoretisch
eine impfpflicht denkbar ist die jetzt
aber so in diesem antrag nicht drin
steht und so wurde jetzt über wochen und
wochen versucht eine einigung zu finden
in der vergangenen woche haben die leute
die die impfpflicht und 18 fordern das
ist der grösste antrag gewesen das waren
ungefähr 230 abgeordnete die haben einen
kompromissvorschlag vorgelegt wo sie
gesagt haben wir machen jetzt erstmal
eine impfpflicht ab 50 und gucken im
herbst noch mal ob wir die dann noch aus
achten auf 18 ausweiten je nachdem wie
sich die pandemie entwickelt wie sich
der ja der im fortschritt entwickelt und
so weiter also einmal ganz kurz die
allgemeine impfpflicht die jetzt
angeordnet werden könnte ist vom tisch
richtig also die allgemeine impfpflicht
ab 18 die ist jetzt erstmal vom dna also
es gibt jetzt keinen antrag mehr ab 18
sondern es gibt jetzt von denen die
überhaupt es gibt ja dann die anträge
der afg und den der union nicht
skizziert habe und noch einen der fdp
einer gruppe um kubicki die wollen keine
impfpflicht und diejenigen die nicht
wollen da gab es bis gestern zwei
anträge einerseits diesen modifizierten
18er antrag der dann ein 50er antrag war
also 50 und gegebenenfalls ausweitung
und dann gab es noch den um den
fdp-politiker android der wollte eine
impfpflicht ab 50 aber nicht sofort
sondern erst meine beratung und dann mal
schauen ob es neben pflicht gibt und
jetzt seit gestern gibt es aber
offensichtlich irgendeine form von
einigung die noch mal in der mitte genau
gestern haben sich jetzt diese beiden
gruppen also ich sage mal die gruppe
ursprünglich 18 jetzt 50 und die gruppe
50 bisschen später also von ullmann
geeinigt und 18 plus 50 macht
bekanntlich 60 also der kompromiss ist
jetzt eine impfpflicht ab 60 aber eine
sofort aktivierte impfpflicht also nicht
eine die erst im herbst irgendwann
wieder beschlossen könne aber die soll
sofort aktiviert wenn allerdings gibt es
jetzt eine opt out möglichkeit im juni
dass man im juni soll der bundestag noch
mal schauen ob die impfpflicht wirklich
nötig ist dann sie gegebenenfalls
aussetzen und dann gibt es für den
herbst noch mal die möglichkeit die dann
wieder auszuweiten plus im register das
ist jetzt der letzte vorschlag von
dienstagabend ist denn dieser vorschlag
jetzt mehrheitsfähig also gehen da jetzt
genug abgeordnete mit auch von der union
also da er der hat etwa ungefähr
300 unterstützer so ist es nur eine
relative mehrheit erforderlich also bei
der abstimmung am morgigen donnerstag
braucht man nicht die kanzlermehrheit
die bei 369 liegt sondern man braucht
nur eine relative mehrheit also der
antrag muss relativ am meisten stimmen
bekommen das ist aber noch nicht ganz
klar also es wird nicht ohne die
mitwirkung der union gehen und diese
mitwirkung kann auch in einer enthaltung
liegen ja allerdings rechnen die ampel
parteien also insbesondere grüne und spd
die das ja vornehmlich stellen diesen
kompromissantrag
rechnen jetzt rum weil natürlich sie
auch eigene leute haben den quarantäne
in sind die in isolation sind wo sonst
was ist und man muss jetzt irgendwie
schauen das ganze steht wirklich auf
sehr
tönernen füßen ist völlig unklar was da
morgen raus kommt es gibt auch noch
darüber hinaus einen streit über die
reihenfolge in der abgestimmt wird dann
die ampel also die ich sag jetzt ampel
das ist natürlich nicht die ampel ich
hab mir erklärt dass es keine
regierungsantrag aber es sind eben vor
allem ampel abgeordnete die wollen gerne
mit dem fdp-antrag anfangen und
sozusagen dann den unions antrag
abstimmen um der union die möglichkeit
zu geben einmal für ihren eigenen antrag
zustimmen und wenn der staat hoffen sie
das doch relativ viele
unions-abgeordnete am ende für diesen 60
+ antrag dann doch stimmen auch darüber
gibt es aber noch keine einigkeit über
diese reihenfolge rinder und die union
will das nicht weil die sozusagen genau
diese gefahr sehen dass sie dann unter
druck geraten eben da doch mit zustimmen
und sie sagen wir sind doch nicht die so
hat es friedrich merz sinngemäß heute
morgen im deutschlandfunk auch gesagt
wir sind doch nicht die steigbügelhalter
für die ampel der die eigene mehrheit
fehlt die wollen gerne die reihenfolge
umkehren und schon über diese frage tobt
ein erbitterter streit mit gegenseitigen
vorwürfen immer zwischen regierung und
opposition also das zeigt im grunde
schon was ich eingangs sagte nämlich
dass dieses gruppen verfahren das
eigentlich ein überparteiliches
verfahren sein soll bei ethischen fragen
sich eben nicht in dieser logik von
opposition und regierung auf zu halten
das ist grandios gescheitert sondern wir
sehen genau das nämlich gegenseitige
schuldzuweisungen und ich hatte mehrere
termine morgen mit abgeordneten die alle
abgesagt wurden weil alle glauben dass
dieses verfahren sich morgen bis in den
nachmittag zieht die debatte und die
abstimmung ist es auch noch könnte
theoretisch auch noch sein dass die
abstimmung ganz ausgesetzt wird weil
niemanden möchte dass es für keinen der
anträge morgen eine mehrheit gibt da
passt ein schicksal ist das jetzt oder
ein szenario ist dass jetzt tatsächlich
droht wo eigentlich sozusagen
mehrheitlich alle politiker gesagt haben
sie wollen eine impfpflicht gibt es für
keinen antrag eine mehrheit das könnte
sein dass man es kurzfristig von der
tagesordnung nimmt jedenfalls
theoretisch es könnte auch sein dass die
zweite lesung morgen gemacht wird und
die dritte dann erst am freitag um den
politikern die möglichkeit zu geben noch
einmal drüber zu schlafen ob sie dann
vielleicht doch zu bestimmen das könnte
auch sein am freitag jedenfalls gibt es
eine bundesratssitzung und wenn das
jetzt doch alles gut geht was ja auch
sein kann dann soll sich schon am
freitag der bundesrat mit dieser frage
beschäftigen und und zustimmen und damit
dann sozusagen den sack zumachen das
dann ganz bald das gesetz in kraft tritt
und diejenigen die noch nicht geimpft
sind dazu verpflichtet sich impfen zu
lassen und dann ab dem 30
verpflichtet zu sein einen nachweis
vorzulegen das wird noch eine sehr
spannende woche wir halten euch
natürlich auf dem laufenden
und haben noch ein drittes corona thema
dabei denn die übergangsfrist ist ja
jetzt aufgelöst gelaufen in sachen
corona schutzmaßnahmen am zweiten april
wir ändern uns relativ kurz vor dem
auslaufen der korona regelung am 19 märz
wurde beschlossen dass jetzt eigentlich
nur noch ein sogenannter basisschutz
gelten soll es sei denn die länder rufen
einen hotspot aus genau das haben jetzt
hamburg und mecklenburg vorpommern auch
getan also im basisschutz das heißt in
allen anderen bundesländern bei die in
berlin und bei mir hier in nrw
gelten eigentlich kaum mehr masken
pflichten nur noch in öffentlichen
verkehrsmitteln usw es gibt keine 2 und
3 g regelungen mehr für die gastronomie
eigentlich gibt es fast nichts mehr
außer masken pflichten zum beispiel in
einrichtungen in denen wohl gerade
personen leben anders jetzt in hamburg
und mecklenburg vorpommern
weil die länder haben von einer ausnahme
gebrauch gemacht die steht in paragraf
28 absatz 8 infektionsschutzgesetz und
da gibt es jetzt halt auch schon richtig
viel trouble also man kann als
landesparlament beschließen dass eine
gebietskörperschaft ein hotspot ist und
da geht es schon los so zu sagen was ist
eine gebietskörperschaft jetzt tritt ein
streit in der ampelkoalition zu tage mit
ein paar wochen verzögerung der ist
schon ehrlich gesagt ein bisschen absurd
und am ende wird die ganze kiste vor den
gerichten danken vermutlich diese
hotspot regelung die besagt dass man
eben weiterhin praktisch fast alle
corona maßnahmen anordnen vor allem geht
es aber immer über die um die massen
pflicht den innenräumen werden entweder
eine neue mutante mit signifikant
höherer pathogenität auftritt oder wenn
aufgrund einer besonders hohen anzahl
von neuinfektionen oder eines besonders
starken anstiegs an neuinfektionen eine
überlastung der krankenhaus kapazitäten
in der jeweiligen gebietskörperschaft
droht jetzt hat hamburg ich glaube die
bundesweit zweitniedrigste inzidenz
mecklenburg vorpommern hat eine relativ
hohe inzidenz beide länder haben ihre
entscheidung sich jetzt zum hotspot
auszurufen im wesentlichen damit
begründet dass sie sagen es droht eine
überlastung im gesundheitssystem und
zwar eben nicht nur was man halt so
kannte zu viele corona patientinnen und
patienten sondern auch zuviel ausfallen
das personal jetzt ist die große frage
darf man sich aus diesen gründen als
hotspot ausrufen und wenn ja dann auch
gleich als ganzes bundesland und da
kommt jetzt hat der streit in der
koalition wirklich stark zum tragen denn
karl lauterbach rät quasi als
gesundheitsminister dazu den ländern
doch bitte mehr gebraucht von der
hotspot regelung zu machen damit man
dann eben mehr corona maßnahmen noch
anordnen könne und schlägt kriterien für
die länder forum eben das sozusagen
diese sehr schwammige vorschrift im 28a
mehr zu definieren während die fdp
darauf hinweist dass die hotspot lösung
an strenge voraussetzungen geknüpft sei
und eindeutig nicht pauschal angewöhnt
angewandt werden dürfe also der
fraktionschef der fdp der herr dürr hat
noch vor einigen tagen gesagt das soll
bitte in einzelnen städten oder kommunen
angewendet werden und nicht in
kompletten ländern anderer ansicht
hamburg und mecklenburg vorpommern
wer soll's jetzt retten vermutlich die
gerichte sie ist dann schon in der
vergangenen woche dass die fdp und die
afg in mecklenburg vorpommern
angekündigt haben klagen zu erheben
auch in hamburg hieß es erst fdp und auf
die afg wollten klagen das hat sich dann
so ein bisschen erledigt in hamburg wird
das jetzt wohl nur ein einzelner
abgeordneter sein und explizit nicht die
fdp ich habe beim verwaltungsgericht in
hamburg schon mal angerufen da liegt
stand dienstagnachmittag noch keine
klage oder kein antrag auf einstweiligen
rechtsschutz vor aber da wird auf jeden
fall was kommen wenn ich von parteien
oder fraktionen daneben von bürgerinnen
und bürgern da steht auf jeden fall fest
dass die anwaltskanzlei herzing aus
berlin die ja schon in den letzten zwei
jahren relativ viele klagen gegen korona
maßnahmen erhoben hat da was vorbereitet
da gibt es also schon klagen mit den
kollegen habe ich gestern mal kurz
gesprochen und habe danach gefragt die
sondieren gerade noch ein bisschen die
lage haben aber definitiv vor der
feststellungsklagen einzureichen die
haben eben auch schon aufträge von
potentiellen mandanten und mandanten
wollen dann natürlich gegen einzelne
regelung vorgehen also man kann jetzt
nicht sagen keine ahnung ich bin gar
nicht mitglied im fitnessstudio ich
möchte aber bitte ohne maske ins
fitnessstudio gehen sondern da braucht
man natürlich betroffene um da klagen zu
können die argumentation ist ja relativ
klar eine vorschrift der verordnung so
nicht gelten weil die zugrundeliegende
verordnung eben jetzt zum beispiel in
hamburg ihrerseits rechtswidrig ist weil
sie quasi die voraussetzung der
ermächtigungsgrundlage vom bund gar
nicht ein hätten da haben wir es ja auch
mit einem problem zu tun dass
vorprogrammiert weil ich kann mich daran
erinnern abtransporte regelung kam dass
man nicht richtig sagen konnte was
eigentlich ein hotspot ist und jetzt
eskaliert die ganze sache auf diese
weise also man kann sagen in der korona
frage wo wir schon lange ein
chaos gesehen haben hat das noch mal
extrem zugenommen ja ich glaube das kann
man auf jeden fall so sagen also diese
diskrepanzen in der in der ampel
regierung eskalieren jetzt natürlich
dann in den ländern ist ja klar wenn man
die verantwortung runter delegiert dann
landet das natürlich das problem dann
irgendwie unten und am ende werden sie
jetzt verwaltungsgerichte entscheiden
müssen ich kann mir durchaus vorstellen
dass die das in diesem fall nicht mit
gehen auch wenn die gerichte ja recht
geduldig waren die letzten zwei jahre
aber ob da jetzt so eine
ermächtigungsgrundlage im
infektionsschutzgesetz überhaupt
hinreichend konkret ist und ob dann die
länder einfach so sagen können na ja
wenn sie nicht konkret ist da machen wir
es einfach mal trotzdem da könnte ich
mir schon vorstellen dass die
verwaltungsgerichte dazwischen haben
so damit sind wir am ende mit dem corona
blog für diese folge und kommen zu einer
sehr sehr aktuellen nachricht heute
morgen gab es nämlich die durchsage
quasi das ist bundesweit durchsuchungen
gibt gegen neonazis helene was ist da
los und gibt es schon informationen zu
irgendwelchen ergebnissen dieser
durchsuchungen ja der
generalbundesanwalt hat eine sehr
ausführliche pressemitteilung verschickt
tatsächlich mehrere seiten lang und es
war auch wohl spektakulär was da heute
morgen geschehen ist in insgesamt elf
bundesländer gab es maßnahmen also vor
allem durchsuchung und es geht hier um
ein rechtsextremes netzwerk das
ausgehoben wurde insgesamt handelt es
sich um 46 beschuldigte gegen die diese
maßnahmen angeordnet wurden vier davon
wurden mit haftbefehl gesucht der jetzt
auch verstärkt von ist es geht um
verschiedene vereinigungen die teilweise
auch unseren hörerinnen und hörern
sicherlich bekannt ist unter anderem die
schon längst verbotene vereinigung
kombat aid in deutschland
steht für also 18 steht für die
buchstaben im alphabet und h also adolf
hitler eine vereinigung die das
bundesinnenministerium schon vor einigen
jahren verboten hat und hier ist jetzt
der vorwurf dass trotz dieses verbots
die mitglieder die ja den zusammenhalt
aufrechterhalten haben im geheimen dass
sie so pflicht treffen veranstaltet
haben also treffen die so sagt dass der
gba als pflicht treffen anzusehen sind
wo man sich versammelt hat wo man
märsche gemeinsam gemacht hat und
ähnliches dann geht es auch noch um die
vereinigung mit dem schönen namen
knockout 51 was der gba als
extremistische kriminelle vereinigung
einstuft was natürlich auch strafbar ist
nach
129 des strafgesetzbuches wo er den
verschiedenen mitgliedern eben nicht nur
für vorwirft diese vereinigung gegründet
zu haben sondern dort auch gewalttätig
gewesen zu sein hier ist die rede von
einsatz von hieb- und stichwaffen und
man wundert sich nicht
er gab es natürlich auch die teilnahme
am protest geschehen gegen die korona
pandemie und dort ist die rede von
gewalttätigen zusammenstößen mit der
polizei die es gegeben habe die auch
diesen mitgliedern von einem sogenannten
lockout 51 zugerechnet wird und zuletzt
auch noch die atomwaffen die vision
deutschland awd auch eine rechtsextreme
vereinigung die ihren ursprung in den
vereinigten staaten hat wo am anfang
nicht ganz klar war was die eigentlich
in deutschland so treiben das ob das nur
reine internet aktivität ist oder nicht
und jetzt so verstehe ich diese
erklärung also der verfassungsschutz
hatte vor einigen jahren noch irgendwie
gesagt hatten es gibt nicht so richtig
viele erkenntnisse was die genau tun das
hat sich offenbar verändert hier ist die
rede davon dass diese mitglieder eben
rassistisch antisemitisch nach außen
treten also in amerika tun sie das und
dass dieser deutsche ableger eben der
dem nicht nach steht also ein großer
schlag gegen die rechtsextreme szene die
dem generalbundesanwalt hoffentlich
heute gelungen ist
[Musik]
und dann kommen wir jetzt wahrscheinlich
wichtigsten prozess der woche dazu
begrüße ich ganz herzlich den kollegen
markus jung aus der wirtschaftsredaktion
und wir sprechen natürlich über hanno
berger vor dem landgericht bonn ist am
montag der prozess losgegangen und
vielleicht fangen wir erst mal damit an
hanno berger formerly known as mister
comex markus wer ist der mann hallo hier
ja vielen dank für die einladung dass
wir uns heute über den fall unterhalten
hanna berger ist lange jahre eine der
renommiertesten steueranwälte in
deutschland gewesen also rechtsanwalt
und steuerberater in der
doppelqualifikation
und hat so über seine tätigkeit in
diversen großkanzleien zugang bekommen
zu großen banken und vor allem auch
gewalt investoren und hat die beraten
vor allen dingen natürlich in
zusammenhang mit transaktionen wie die
bestimmte vermögenswerte natürlich
besonders steuermindernd ansetzen können
oder 90 bei steuerstrukturen die optimal
eingesetzt werden konnten aus sicht
seiner mandanten natürlich denn das
sollte man vielleicht auch noch sagen
den ursprung seiner karriere lag in der
finanzverwaltung also hornberger hat
begonnen vor langen jahren in der
hessischen finanzverwaltung und hatte es
dort geschafft auch der karriere gemacht
bis zum höchsten banken prüfer in hessen
und wenn man natürlich weiß dass der
finanzplatz frankfurt ist dann ist da
natürlich bei den großen privatbanken
oder geschäftsbanken draußen eingang
kannte natürlich deren geschäft und nach
dem wechsel in diverse großkanzleien
aber sehr aktiv wortschatz aber war
schon sterling und auch bei der kanzlei
war zeitweise auch deutschland managing
partner hat heute dieses geschäft
natürlich in diesem wissen natürlich
transferierten auf eine andere seite
gebracht und der galt ja nun auch eine
ganze zeit lang als faktisch unantastbar
also ich sag mal vielleicht vor zehn
oder auch 15 jahren wäre es undenkbar
gewesen dass hanno berger heutzutage vor
gericht steht ja sowohl wenn man ihn
kennt als person also wir so körperlich
und als person rüberkommt und natürlich
auch vom know how was man vielleicht ein
bisschen aufzusplitten wer die person
hanno berger nicht kennt das ist ein ein
mann auch heute mit 71 jahren
eine sehr imposante erscheinung ist also
deutlich über 1 meter 90 groß sehr
breite schultern sehr breit gebaut ein
wuchtiger großer mann als starker mann
der auch entsprechend natürlich seinen
organen laut einsetzen konnte das wissen
wir aus diversen artikeln
beziehungsweise auch büchern die
mittlerweile über das innenleben seiner
früheren kanzlei geschrieben wurden das
war es auch ich aus diversen gesprächen
die ich im rahmen meiner recherche
geführt haben dass das also nicht immer
ganz leise zugehen in der kanzleramt uhr
sozusagen
und wenn man natürlich eine kombination
so ein auftreten fachwissen und halt auf
der anderen seite hat ein unglaublich
gutes netzwerk sehr viele kontakte war
sehr einflussreich sowohl und nicht nur
in der wirtschaft nicht nach und
schafften die politik rein kam er
unlängst berichtete dass gerade im
zusammenhang mit der fdp ist sehr enge
kontakte gegeben hat aber nicht nur vor
allem halt auch in die verbände rein in
die ministerien und da aller forderst
die jetzt für unseren fall sehr
relevanten natürlich das
bundesfinanzministerium da hat er
offenbar wirklich ist geschafft in die
relevanten
fachabteilungen leute zu platzieren die
ihnen da immer regelmäßig und gut
informiert haben über neue gesetze und
verordnungen die da kommen sollten
trotzdem hat visa ich sage mal ehemalige
stars ich kann im jahr 2012 abgesetzt
als der boden in sachen comics ziemlich
heiß wurde und zwar in die schweiz und
hat seitdem nie wieder deutschen boden
betreten oder das stimmt die herrschaft
in frankfurt hatten november 2012 die
damalige kanzler berge die ermittler
darin gegründet hatte mit dem niemand ja
heute war es kronzeugen der
staatsanwaltschaft in köln
und die wurde durchsucht und hannover
das mitbekommen hat auch mitbekommen
dass die polizei bei ihnen zu hause in
der nähe von frankfurt gewesen ist auf
seinem privatanwesen und hat sich dann
postwendend abgesetzt in die schweiz zur
schon vorher einen zweiten wohnsitz
hatte im kanton graubünden noch knapp
1800 metern höhe der beetle 30 sehr
schönes tor da hat er dann tatsächlich
die letzten jetzt werden muss man etwas
sagen zehn jahre gelebt bis dann ist
natürlich auch zwischendurch suchen
gegeben als vor einigen jahren dabei
wurde letztes jahr im sommer gab es dann
also besuch von der polizei die dann in
abschiebehaft genommen
wie kam es denn eigentlich dazu wenn ich
das mal kurz zwischenfragen darf die
schweiz liefert ja normalerweise bei
steuerhinterziehung nicht aus genau
kurzer exkurs
steuerhinterziehung
wird in der schweiz vom dortigen fiskus
nicht als fiskal straftat gesehen
sondern nur als ordnungswidrigkeit die
alleine berechtigt nicht zur
auslieferung an das
heimatland deutschland da sind ganz
wichtiger punkt wo die schweizer ist
aber deutlich kritischer sehen ist beim
stichwort anlagebetrug das war aber auch
den deutschen behörden klar allerdings
musste man da erst auf ein deutliches
signal vom oberlandesgericht frankfurt
es warten das kann nämlich auch eine
auseinandersetzung in deutschland
zwischenzeitlich wegen den haftbefehlen
die gegen berga vorlagen aus wiesbaden
und dann hat das olg frankfurt
entschieden dass die von berger
mutmaßlich begangenen taten auch nicht
nur eine schwere steuerhinterziehung und
erstellen können sondern einen
gewerbsmäßigen
bandenbetrug und damit waren wir
gewissermaßen im boot weil ja dann auch
von deutscher sicht qualifiziert wurde
im moment mal das was da passiert ist
damals in dem zeitraum träger taten die
zwischen 2 7 und 12 jetzt liegen
zumindest darüber dass bonner verfahren
sprechen das ist nicht nur eine station
ist kein betrug sein na und daraufhin
kam es zum umdenken um firma weiter bei
den schweizer behörden die haben berger
dann festgesetzt dann jetzt mehrere
monate in abschiebehaft in schweizer
gefängnissen hat sich dagegen gewehrt
sowohl bis zum bundesstrafgericht das
ist so vergleichbar mit den straftaten
beim bgh als das dann kurz vor
weihnachten gegen ihn entschieden hat
beschwerde zurückgewiesen wurde hat er
sich noch weiter gewendet an das
bundesgericht in lausanne das ist dann
gewissermaßen nochmal eine stufe weiter
oben drüber man würde fast sagen das ist
wahrscheinlich dann nochmal übergeordnet
das bundesverfassungsgericht dass ich
dann noch mal mit dem fall
auseinandersetzen müssten auch daher gab
es dann vor wenigen wochen die
entscheidung nein die abschiebe
entscheidung gegen hanno berger hat
bestand er wurde also ausgeliefert in
konz es wurde dann in gewahrsam genommen
direkt von staatsanwältin aus frankfurt
verbracht in eigentlich zu sein
stattdessen und da sitzt er jetzt und
muss jetzt dann pendeln user maßen
beziehungsweise er nicht wie jetzt heute
wieder ganz jüngst ist
dann kommen wir jetzt mal zu dem
verfahren das jetzt vom landgericht bonn
losgegangen ist was wird ihm da jetzt
eigentlich genau vorgeworfen vielleicht
einmal faktisch und wir sind ja noch der
einspruch podcast auch rechtlich also
welche delikte werden denn zu last
gelegt also der hacker soll in den
jahren dass man muss mal klarstellen
berge auch wenn es immer mal wieder
anders dargestellt wird ist nicht per se
der erfinder dieses event dividenden
stripping soder diese aktien kreis
geschäfte sondern die wurden schon zuvor
lange jahre praktiziert zwischen den
banken selbst aber was man sagen kann
berger ist einer der ersten die es
geschafft hat darunter anschaltung
verschiedene andere akteure depotbanken
aber vor allen dingen leerverkäufer im
ausland dieses prinzip dieses dividenden
strings unter einbehaltung von
kapitalertragsteuer auszahlen oder
mehrfach erstellung von kapitalströmen
steuern die sony angefallen sind das zu
öffnen für privatinvestoren und zwar
irgendwann wieder als auch verschiedene
dokumentiert ist ab dem jahr 2006
spätestens mit der idee ist man
natürlich dann von dort aus zu
verschiedenen bank gegangen und hat dann
da auch gleichgesinnte getroffen die
namen die da zu nennen sind sind vor
allem die hamburger privatbank mm
warburg die kennen ja auch schon viele
aus den ersten comics strafprozessen die
schon bereits am landgericht bonn laufen
gelaufen sind
dann muss man sich nur nennen den
londoner zweig der hypovereinsbank denn
da haben aktienhändler fleißig geholfen
die aktien strukturen auch
voranzubringen und natürlich auch zu
platzieren dann gab es noch ein großes
brokerhaus in das gibt es noch das nennt
sich icap hat damit geholfen aktien
nicht zu organisieren weil man damit
natürlich auch massiv vermögenswerte in
milliardenhöhe bewegen musste um am
schluss dann in ertrag zu erzielen in
dieser millionenhöhe wenn man das jetzt
bewertet was da passiert ist was die
anwälte gemacht und sie haben nicht nur
die investoren herangebracht
zusammengebracht mit mit den banken mit
den brokern sollen die hand noch die
gesellschaftsrechtlichen strukturen
aufgesetzt weil das natürlich
letztendlich nicht immer eine
privatperson macht sondern die
investiert in fonds die investiert über
eine stiftung die investiert
letztendlich dann auch über
us-pensionsfonds das sind die letzte
strukturen ließ dann gab und somit comex
da waren die die anwälte der der
früheren kanzler von arno berger aktiv
nach ansicht der staatsanwaltschaft und
deswegen werdet man das als stand teil
der schweren steuerhinterziehung ist
aber noch ein stück weiter gegangen
haben schon über den tod gesprochen und
sieht auch eine qualifikation des
betrugs wenn wir den strafräumen
sprechen muss berger in dem bonner
verfahren mit einer im falle einer
verurteilung
mit love rush hour von bis zu zehn
jahren rechnen daher im november 72 wird
wie wir geschrieben haben bedeutet es
also selbst wenn der prozess schnell
fertig sein würde und die sache zum bgh
geht wird irgendwas noch sehr sehr lange
beschäftigen ihn sein werden und der
vorwurf an ihnen selbst ist ja dass sie
sich quasi selbst und sein
kanzleipartner der eben mittlerweile als
als grund zeuge ausgesagt hat in dem
ersten glaube ich com express wenn ich
mich da nicht täuschen dass er sich
quasi selbst bereichert hat also rund 27
millionen euro werden ihm zur last
gelegten und eben diese diese massive
schädigung des staates da geht es ja um
dreistellige millionensummen die keiner
im prinzip genau beziffern kann korrekt
genau davon verwertete den zweiten punkt
mal aufgegriffen es geht in dem in dem
bonner verfahren um behaupteten
steuerschaden von 278 millionen euro das
stimmt die summe ist natürlich noch ein
bisschen
genauer aufgeschlüsselt weil ich ohne
das jetzt mal so aufzuhören
und tatsächlich ist es so dass er
natürlich dann berater honorare bekommen
hat und dann kommen wir zu dem thema was
hätte daraus verdient wie ist dann
eigentlich seine persönliche
bereicherung in der thematik dann ist
natürlich auch eine frage die sich in
der späteren vermögensabschöpfung
natürlich auch stellt das hat er aus
diesen geschäften verdient das hat dafür
gewinnen rausgezogen das kann man bei
ihm herausholen da weiß man dass man in
diesem den komplex der jetzt in bonn
geht insgesamt
ungefähr ein zehntel des gewinns
bekommen hat über eine vereinbarung die
gingen gemeinsam an ihnen sagen
damaligen kanzleipartner so dass man
also passfoto sagen kann 720 millionen
roundabout zwischen den beiden oder
nochmals gesplittet 13 bis 14 millionen
die da konkret im raum stehen was man
natürlich auch aus früheren berichten
war heiß und aus der ermittlungen dass
er insgesamt der hat ja auch teilweise
selbst mit investiert hat aber auch vor
dem halt viel über die honorare
rausgezogen und dieses geld ist
eingeflossen in eine stiftung die
aufgesetzt hat sie sich auf einer
karibischen inseln in einer steueroase
befindet da steht im raum dass es bis um
bis zu 50 millionen euro gilt als wir
ihn damals in der schweiz damit
konfrontiert hat also das aber
abgestritten dass es solche summen geht
also berger hält sich ja auch zumindest
in der recht lauten kommunikation
weiterhin für quasi politisch verfolgt
er hält das alles für eine für eine
hetzkampagne für eine medienkampagne und
man muss ja jetzt mal per se zu seiner
ehrenrettung auch sagen dass ja sehr
lange davon ausgegangen wurde inklusive
gutachten einfach aussetzen
entsprechender steuerrechtlicher
kommentar literatur und so weiter dass
die comex deals nicht strafbar sein und
offensichtlich hält berger an dieser
auffassung dass heute fest obwohl
mittlerweile der bundesgerichtshof der
bundesfinanzhof eigentlich alle
relevanten gerichte bestätigt haben es
war strafbar das da kapitalertragsteuer
erstattet wurde die nie gezahlt wurde ja
da musste glaube ich jetzt verschiedene
zeitraum sehen es gibt
bfh-rechtsprechung 1999 titel sich damit
beschäftigen auch die man sich damals
sehr stark konzentriert und hat
natürlich immer versucht die gutachten
oder usa die seine position stützen
natürlich immer ganz stark im
vordergrund zu stellen und wie alt ich
ja vom naturell ist alle anderen punkte
die gegen seine position sprechen auch
im wahrsten sinn des wortes klein zu
machen was man aber auch mittlerweile
weiß ist dass er nicht nur die guten
beziehungen die wir eben schon sprachen
in die ministerien hatte und in die
industrien die verbände sondern sind die
natürlich auch genutzt hat in die
finanzgerichtsbarkeit dass er auch gute
kontakte hatten hier
rechtswissenschaften und man da auch
weiß dass er natürlich einflussreichen
autoren gelder versprochen hat die dann
auch geflossen sind dann die
entsprechende literatur publizieren wir
müssen mal müssten ja alle es gibt
herrschende meinung es gibt minder
meinung und wenn natürlich drei tolle
autoren meine position stützen da bin
ich entsprechend auch er die herrschende
meinung hat auch selbst publiziert in
kommentaren man muss auch sagen dass in
diesem ganzen konstrukt und dass wir
jetzt hier sprechen gerichte
einflussnahme in verschiedene
verbandsebene aber auch natürlich wie es
im ersten bonner verfahren auch mal
genannt wurde sogar mit schreiber rein
also quasi bewusst autoren einsetzen
damit die eigene position passt das
alles alles dazu geführt hat dass er
natürlich ein konstrukt hatte in dem er
sagt moment mal das ist hier herrscht
einmal das ist meine meinung die wird
gestützt und so hat er über die ganzen
jahre ja auch immer argumentiert wie du
eben schon gesagt hast mittlerweile ist
so bgh hatte im juli 2021 bestätigt
comex in der form in der es veranstaltet
wurde ist strafbar als schwerer
steuerhinterziehung und der bfh hat im
märz also vor wenigen wochen erst
entschieden wenn ein vehikel aufgesetzt
wird wir haben vorhin schon mal kurz
über die us pensionsfonds gesprochen
dass ausschließlich nur dass dafür
gedacht ist und gewerbsmäßig oder
geschäftsmäßig daran teilzunehmen eine
tatsächlich nicht abgeführte
kapitalertragsteuer mehrfach sich
zurückerstatten zu lassen dann kann das
nicht rechtens sein dann haben sie
diesen geschäftsprinzip eine absage
erteilt und gewissermaßen auch sich an
den aussagen vom bgh orientiert was die
strafbarkeit und wie ist hanna berger
jetzt gestern aufgetreten was ich
gesehen habe ist natürlich dass die
große öffentlichkeit ihnen hat ihn ja
zehn jahre nicht wahrgenommen es gibt
ganz wenige interviews mit ihm vor allem
print interviews ist natürlich ein
mensch der über zehn jahre gealtert ist
er wirkt einerseits körperlich ein
bisschen angeschlagen das haben seine
beiden strafverteidiger die
pflichtverteidiger vor dem
prozessauftakt ja auch ganz klar gesagt
sie haben ihr mandant jetzt erst mal
empfohlen sich nicht zuordnen zu den
folgen dann klar gesagt dass herberger
durch die mehrere monate in der
abschiebungshaft beziehungsweise in der
u-haft in
frankfurt aber natürlich körperlich
geschwächt ist dass das spuren
hinterlassen hat das ist weiterhin ein
sehr imposante positiv auftretender
mensch man hat auch mitbekommen dass er
tatsächlich
sich mit vielen dingen die ihr da sich
anhören musste eine anklage nicht
zufrieden war hat mir einfach nur im
kopf geschüttelt hat sich viel mit
seinen verteidigern beraten und es gab
natürlich auch im moment um das hat er
auch wieder zeiten beschrieben weil dass
er am anfang dieses prozesses auf einmal
wieder derjenige war der die dinge
geleitet hat weil er nämlich auf
bestimmte unterlagen noch warten musste
man hatte sich notizen gemacht die waren
noch nicht da daraufhin hat der prozess
sich um eine knappe viertelstunde
verzögert ist nur eine kleine anekdote
aber was man habe jetzt zeigen will ist
das natürlich für ihn auch ein kleiner
moralischer oder kleiner triumph war
dass er derjenige als angeklagter sich
dann doch mal wie derjenige wieder war
um den sich alles dreht und das hat er
glaube ich ganz gut genossen aber was in
diesem ominösen karton ist die weiß man
jetzt noch nicht das heißt das sind
unterlagen drin mit denen er sich
angeblich entlasten will da waren
weitere unterlagen die natürlich wieder
dazu dienen sollten die er gerne macht
sich zu entlasten
was ein bier mitbekommen haben ist das
ist ein besonderes exemplar der anklage
schutzes anklage gesagt es war in dem er
sich notizen gemacht hatte weil es das
vorgetragen wurde von frau pauli kann
beziehungsweise den weiteren vertretern
von stadt verschafft köln hat er
natürlich mit gelesen hat sich
entsprechend selbst nochmal notizen
gemacht und entsprechend zu wort du hast
sie gerade schon angesprochen die kölner
staatsanwältin anne behälter ist ja
mittlerweile eine gefürchtete comex
jägerin geworden wahrscheinlich die
komikerin in deutschland sie ist also
seine gegenspielerin wer ist die kammer
wer sind die richterinnen und richter
also der konzentrieren
wie viele andere juristen auch eine
banklehre gemacht hat also eine gewisse
affinität zu den banken themen kommt
eigentlich aus dem zivilrecht hat er
lange jahre auch als vorsitzender einer
zivilkammer in bonn gearbeitet
da auch erfahrung macht sie insbesondere
wenn banken themen aber auch thema
diesel sich beschäftigt also diese fälle
sind eben auch nicht unbekannt und als
dann klar war dass ich über die
zuständigkeit des landgerichts bonn für
viele comics fälle das sollte man noch
mal kurz zu sagen dass nicht folgen da
an das bundeszentralamt für steuern
sitzt in bonn und dort sind viele
depotbanken und banken mit den steuer
bescheinigen hin für ihre mandanten und
die wurden da gewissermaßen eingereicht
das heißt also quasi gold war wenn man
so sagen der physische ort der
steuerhinterzieher oder jetzt versucht
der steuerhinterziehung deswegen war ich
recht schnell klar ist wird sich viel in
bonn ab stattfinden und da hat die
justiz in der organisation und das land
gesagt wir könnten hier neue große
strafkammer eine große wirtschaftsmacht
kann so ist ja damals in
2018 auf die wirtschaft schafft gekommen
die dann ab dem herbst 2009 10 fast
ausschließlich da bin ich mir jetzt
nicht 100 prozent sicher aber ich mag es
schon fast ausschließlich diese comex
fälle macht und das ist jetzt das vierte
verfahren dass ziegler für das erste
verfahren war gegen zwei britische
börsenhändler gingen mit milden urteil
mit bewährungsstrafen zu ende aber nötig
auch mit der hans die einziehung
anordnung von 166 millionen euro bei der
wahl über die wir viel spannung das ist
übrigens der fall der bis zum bgh ging
also die grundlage hat er geschaffen
dafür dass comex geschäfte strafbar sind
danach folgten noch zwei andere prozesse
gegen ehemalige mitarbeiter der
warburg-bank und jetzt ist man daran
diesen prozess weiter aufzudröseln
geschäft sich jetzt mit der berater
ebene hanna berger ist der erste
rechtsanwalt der sich mit diesem thema
beschäftigen hält deutschlands
finanzindustrie jetzt den atem an also
ob und was berger möglicherweise auch
über wien auspacken könnte das weiß ich
nicht aber ich habe mit anderen gästen
gesprochen die den fall aus intensiv
betreuen und gut kennen es ist nicht
auszuschließen dass berger da noch den
ein oder andern spinnen oder eine
überraschung bereit hält es ist jetzt
auch schon klar das wird ein sehr
intensives verfahren in bonn geführt
werden der wird er nicht geschont werden
sind ab donnerstag schon die ersten
zeugen geladen und es ist erst mal
terminiert bis in den sommer ein die
kammer in bonn hat bislang sehr
strukturiert gearbeitet
und man muss abwarten wie er die
doppelbelastung mit einem zweiten
verfahren in wiesbaden das wie ich
vorhin kurz angekündigt habe eigentlich
hätte der nächste woche starten müssen
vielleicht ganz kurz einmal rein gefragt
wieso gibt es denn überhaupt zwei
verfahren und wieso laufen die parallel
zueinander weiß unterschiedliche lebens
abfall sind in dem bonner verfahren geht
es um die beratung und tätigkeiten
zusammen aber die große klammer ist und
bleibt die geschäfte der privatbank mm
warburg
währenddessen wir im wiesbadener
verfahren
historisch viel früher da geht es um
comics geschäfte die alle berge
abgewickelt haben soll auch wieder unter
mitarbeiter der hypovereinsbank für
einen immobilieninvestor der
zwischenzeitlich verstorben deswegen
kann man den namen jetzt hier auch mal
nennen raphael roth der da auch
investiert hat sich in comics geschäfte
und das geht also unterschiedliche
lebenssachverhalte die in wiesbaden
schon seit 2010 angeklagt waren berger
hat sich diesem verfahren bruder uns
auch gesagt hätte würde ich diesen
verfahren stellen erst mal gezogen hat
herzlich atteste vorgelegt dann kam es
zu der abschiebung wird die wir jetzt
auch schon gesprochen haben und
normalerweise hätte man auch aus
prozessökonomie oder effizienz willen
das einfach schnell voranzutreiben
beide verfahren koppeln können das wurde
auch vielfach in den medien angesprochen
man hätte vermutlich auch eine bereits
erfahren dort kammer das zutrauen können
diese sachverhalte zusammenzufassen aber
der springende punkt ist da müssen sich
auch die staatsanwaltschaften einigen
das hat offenbar nicht funktioniert das
haben die gerichte auch dann
zwischenzeitig kommuniziert dass er
seine zustimmung bei der
staatsanwaltschaft sowohl
staatsanwaltschaft köln als auch
generalstaatsanwaltschaft frankfurt
bedingt hätte und das hat nicht
stattgefunden
dadurch haben wir die situation berger
in zwei prozessen das heißt die gerichte
müssen sich auch ständig ab also weil
diese prozesstage ja nicht parallel
stattfinden dürfen ja es sind
unterschiedliche tage er wird dann immer
mit einem auto der justiz hin und her
gefahren diese knapp 160 kilometer aber
hat jetzt ein bisschen spielraum
gewonnen auch die stc spielraum gewonnen
weil wir gerade heute morgen kurz bevor
wir miteinander jetzt in diesem podcast
aufnehmen hat das landgericht wiesbaden
mitgeteilt weil sich der neue
pflichtverteidiger noch länger in den
fall einarbeiten muss wills der
prozessauftakt er will kommende woche
angesetzt war und zwar wurde verschoben
das wiesbadener verfahren gegen hannover
beginnt also erst
diesen kleinen bogen können wir jetzt
vielleicht auch noch mal gerade machen
denn die eigentlichen verteidiger von
hanno berger haben ihre man haben ihr
mandat niedergelegt vor kurzem in dem
wiesbadener verfahren in beiden
verfahren denn auch in boulder verfahren
hat der pflichtverteidiger ein
strafverteidiger aus boll und der handel
sollte die jetzt nicht die dezidierten
steuer strafrechtler sind oder
wirtschaftsrechtler das steht ja auch
bei uns in der zeitung dass der eine
eher mit kapitalverbrechen zu tun hatte
oder einem anderen milieu tätig gewesen
ist und ja in wiesbaden ist das genau
das gleiche
der hacker hatte
neben einem kapitalmarktrechtler noch
zwei strafverteidiger aus bayern
mandatiert ganz früher im wiesbadener
verfahren war sogar mal wolfgang kubicki
als einer von mehreren strafverteidigern
aufgeführt hat das mandat aber schon vor
längerer zeit niedergelegt und diese
wird man diese drei als strafverteidiger
haben vor ein paar wochen das mandat
niedergelegt wie man so hört aus dem
umfeld und was man aus verließ geht es
ein bisschen um das thema
beratungsresistenz und wie ich schon
gesagt habe die personen nur berger er
bestimmt halt gerne weiterhin selbst und
hatten gerade eine hand und da hat es
offenbar eine zusammenarbeit mit anderen
sehr erfahrenen
dann darf man jetzt sehr gespannt sein
welche fäden hanno berger in den
nächsten monaten in der hand behalten
kann markus ich danke dir es sehr für
dieses update zum prozessbeginn ich bin
mir sicher wir werden von den noch
einiges hören zu einem oder beiden
verfahren die jetzt auf hanna berger zu
kommen vielen dank
dann kommen wir jetzt zu einer
entscheidung des europäischen
gerichtshofs zu unserem lieblings thema
vorratsdatenspeicherung ist schon die
gefühl zehnte entscheidung des ogh dazu
in diesem fall geht es auch nicht um
einen deutschen fall sondern um einen
irischen und zwar um einen sehr
grausamen sexualmord der auch schon
einige jahre zurückliegt der mann der
wegen dieses mordes verurteilt worden
ist moniert dass telekommunikationsdaten
verwendet worden sein um ihn zu
verurteilen
diese daten hätten nicht erhoben und
nicht verwendet werden dürfen in den
strafverfahren gegen ihn und das hat
dann am ende ein irisches gericht im
original vorgelegt der jetzt entschieden
hat und da vielleicht mal als
allererstes warum ist das überhaupt für
deutschland relevanten genau das ist ja
auch noch ein deutsches was man anhängig
und zwar schon seit einigen jahren
ursprünglich wollte der gerichtshof wohl
beide verfahren zusammenfassen das hat
er jetzt aber nicht getan sondern
erstmal über den irischen fall geurteilt
aber man kann daraus ziemlich klar
ableiten wie das deutsche verfahren wohl
ausgehen wird die ag hat jetzt wirklich
du hast gesagt gefühlt das 10 das mache
ich glaube dass bestimmt so ungefähr es
hat etwas weniger er hat aber diese
leitplanken für die
vorratsdatenspeicherung jetzt wirklich
schon relativ häufig klar gezogen und in
diesem fall noch einmal indem er sagt
dass die speicherung von verkehrs und
standortdaten
nur bei einer ernsten bedrohung für die
nationale sicherheit zulässig ist also
gerade nicht bei einem quasi einzelnen
kriminalfall egal wie schwer der auch
sein mag richtig genau also er
unterscheidet eben zwischen der
nationalen sicherheit und der
öffentlichen sicherheit und das ist ja
wahrscheinlich im täglichen
sprachgebrauch ist es durchaus was mal
durcheinander gehen kann und der bgh
sagt aber ziemlich klar in dieser
entscheidung der großen kammer dass das
zwei völlig unterschiedliche dinge sind
nationale sicherheit definiert als ein
angriff auf die tragenden strukturen
eines landes einer unmittelbaren
bedrohung der bevölkerung und nennt als
beispiel angriffe von terroristen also
eine punktuelle gefährdung des staates
in seinen grundfesten würde ich jetzt
mal mit meiner eigenen worten sein und
sagt dann die störung der öffentlichen
sicherheit durch straftaten sei damit
eben überhaupt gar nicht zu vergleichen
denn das sei eine dauerhafte sozusagen
anhaltende gefahr was ja auch stimmt
also straftaten auch schwere straftaten
sind zeit immer und nach dieser logik
sozusagen könnte man halt alle vorab
datenspeicher speichern und sie dann
eben verwenden wenn es wieder und wieder
zu straftaten kommt und da hat er jetzt
noch einmal klargestellt dass ist nicht
gemeint also schwerste kriminalität ist
ein dauerproblem mit dem man
anders fertig werden muss jetzt ist die
frage wie wird man denn damit anders
fertig und da hat der rgh jetzt
verschiedene möglichkeiten aufgezeigt
und das ist jetzt schon neun also dass
der ogh so konkret sagt dass könntet ihr
aber machen das ist jetzt glaube ich
schon also es hat da schon auch immer
wieder angedeutet dass das nicht zu
verstehen ist als völliges aus für die
vorratsdatenspeicherung aber jetzt hat
er relativ genau in fünf spiegel
strichen glaube ich die maßnahmen
aufgezeigt die seines erachtens möglich
sind und vereinbar sind eben mit der
grundrechte-charta denn darum geht es ja
also das recht auf schutz des
privatlebens und
also achtung des privatlebens zu heißt
es genau und den der schutz der
personenbezogenen daten sowas ist jetzt
das worauf sich die ampel parteien
sofort gestürzt haben von diesen spiegel
strichen das ist das sogenannte
quick freeze verfahren das der gh
ausdrücklich für zulässig erklärt da
sieht es so aus dass
strafverfolgungsbehörden
die im falle einer schweren straftat der
meinung sind sie brauchen diese
telekommunikationsdaten die können die
quasi einfrieren lassen sprich den
telekommunikationsanbietern verbieten
die zu löschen dann wenn wir erst mal
eingefroren und bevor sie dann verwendet
werden dürfen bis da ein richter noch
mal zustimmen also man könnte sozusagen
punktuell die löschung verhindern und
dann aber in einem jahr verfahren wo
natürlich dann auch die ganze
verhältnismäßigkeit und alles geprüft
wird die daten wieder aufbauen denn das
problem ist ja dass wenn die
telekommunikationsanbieter nicht zum zur
speicherung verpflichtet werden löschen
sie die daten sobald sie die nicht mehr
brauchen und das wird eben dazu dass sie
dann auch nicht mehr rekonstruiert
werden können also das ist ein wenn man
so will vorgriff auf das deutsche
verfahren dass jetzt irgendwann zur
entscheidung steht worauf ja auch die
ampel wartet die ampel hatte in ihrem
koalitionsvertrag gesagt dass sie nur
eine anlassbezogene und durch
richterlichen beschluss zugelassene
speicherung möchte will aber eben das
ogh urteil abwarten das kommt bestimmt
irgendwann ist es aber nicht davon
auszugehen weil der bgh jetzt schon fast
genervt immer wieder diese eine linie
betont ist wirklich überhaupt gar nicht
davon auszugehen dass das deutsche
verfahren irgendwie anders ausgeht als
das irische das heißt aber diese quick
freeze lösung also quasi die daten
werden erst mal gespeichert aber nur bis
zu einem zeitpunkt wo daneben ein
richter sagt wir brauchen die jetzt die
strafverfolgungsbehörden dürfen die in
diesem fall haben die ist ja von der
ampel koalition durchaus angestrebt und
das wäre ja schon eine lösung mit der
alle relativ gut leben könnten oder wenn
es dabei bleibt da gab's gestern von
fdp-politikern also constantin kohle der
stellvertretende fraktionsvorsitzende
und auch von dem rechtspolitischen
sprecher der grünen sofort das signal ja
quick freeze lösung damit können wir gut
leben das ist aus sicht der ampel ein
gleichgewicht zwischen den legitimen
forderungen der strafverfolgungsbehörden
einerseits und andererseits eben diesem
ja die ampel hat ja insbesondere fdp und
grüne ein großes unbehagen bei der
vorstellung dass eben massenhaft daten
gespeichert werden für den möglichen
fall dass man sie irgendwann mal
brauchen kann dass es ja dieser streit
um die vorratsdatenspeicherung
der ich würde fast sagen 20 jahre alt
ist das stimmt wahrscheinlich nicht ganz
aber aber fünf schuss auf jeden fall
würde ich auch sind es nur noch mal ganz
kurz wir haben zwischen mehrfach darüber
gesprochen aber nur zur erinnerung es
gibt ja in deutschland ein gesetz aus
dem jahr 215 das damals verabschiedet
wurden nach etlichen vorläufern schon
das dann erst mal in kraft war dass nach
einer entscheidung des ovg nrw das
zweifel hatte ob das mit dem europarecht
vereinbar ist in faktisch nicht mehr zur
anwendung kommt weil die
bundesnetzagentur gesagt hat also sie
verfolgt jetzt erstmal verstöße nicht so
dass dieses gesetz zwar einerseits gilt
aber eben nicht angewandt wird und das
ist jetzt auch schon eine situation die
wir seit sieben jahren haben also zeit
dass ich da mal etwas tut dafür hat er
jetzt immerhin mal im ansatz
voraussetzungen geschaffen da kann man
sich gut vorstellen dass das dann in
deutschland so oder ähnlich umgesetzt
wird mit dem quick freeze verfahren
jetzt haben wir nochmal europa am wickel
mit einer auch schwierigen geschichte
indem ich das rechtsstaats verfahren
gegen ungarn ungarn hat das haben sich
ja nicht alle hörerinnen und hörer
mitbekommen am sonntag gewählt und
viktor orban der ja umstrittene
staatschef ist mit großer mehrheit
größer als die beobachter erwartet
hatten im amt bestätigt worden es ändert
sich an den mehrheitsverhältnissen
überhaupt nichts diese wahl wollte die
eu kommission abwarten und jetzt hat sie
aber gesagt jetzt kann man nicht weiter
dabei zu gucken was sich in ungarn topia
worum geht es da ganz genau viktor orban
hat mit 53 prozent gewonnen das bedeutet
dass es im prinzip alles beim alten
bleibt du hast es schon gesagt der kann
so im prinzip weiter verfassungsändernde
also verfassungsänderungen beschließen
mit einer eigenen mehrheit und man muss
davon ausgehen dass er sein anti eu kurs
fortsetzen wird das hat dann jetzt die
eu-kommission man muss ehrlich sagen
endlich mal zum anlass genommen
anzukündigen dass sie den den
sogenannten rechtsstaats mechanismus in
kraft setzen will der organen das auch
gerne die konditionalität verordnung wir
haben euch das ist etwas ausführlicher
vorgestellt in der folge 199 und 23
februar
weil damals der ogh der europäische
gerichtshof diese konditionalität
verordnung belegt hatte damit stand dann
eigentlich schon fest also quasi ende
februar dass man den rechtsstaats
mechanismus jetzt in kraft setzen könnte
hat dann erstmal noch keiner getan weil
man die wahl in ungarn noch abwarten
wollte jetzt ist die wahl durch alle
befürchten was heißt alle aber die
allermeisten pro europäer sag ich mal
befürchten dass es in ungarn weiter
gehen wird wie bisher vor allem in
sachen korruption und deshalb hat man
jetzt gesagt wir setzen den rechtsstaats
mechanismus kraft rechtsstaats
mechanismus was heißt das auf deutsch
bedeutet dass kein rechtsstaat in einem
mitgliedstaat keine kohle von der eu
also man versucht eigentlich die
mitgliedstaaten vor allem polen und
ungarn und die geht es im wesentlichen
im moment dazu zu bekommen
minimale rechtsstaatliche standards
einzuhalten indem man ihnen ansonsten
eu-fördergelder kürzt an polen will die
eu jetzt wohl noch nicht ran in polen
geht es ja meist um den abbau der justiz
das wäre wahrscheinlich auch im moment
ein schlechter moment da polen sicher
gerade sehr an die seite der anderen
westlichen staaten stellt in sachen
ukraine krieg während viktor orban sich
weiterhin als russlandfreundlich zitiert
und im besten falle sagt dass es nicht
unser krieg er hat also nach der wahl am
sonntag auch den ukrainischen
präsidenten wohl odyssee lenski als
feind von ungarn bezeichnet es gibt also
schon gute gründe dagegen umgang jetzt
vorzugehen es gab tatsächlich auch
gestern als ursula von der leyen die eu
kommissionspräsident in bekannt gegeben
hat dass der rechtsschutz mechanismus
jetzt in gang gesetzt werden soll
applaus im eu-parlament für diese
entscheidung bis die gelder jetzt
gekürzt werden kann es allerdings
wirklich noch dauern die regierung in
budapest hassan noch mehrfach die
gelegenheit zur äußerung vorher und
mindestens 15 eu-staaten die wiederum
mindestens 65 prozent der eu bevölkerung
ausmachen müssen auch noch zustimmen
allerdings kann man wohl davon ausgehen
dass die zustimmung da groß genug ist
dass da gegen ungarn vorgegangen werden
wird in ungarn geht es eben wie gesagt
vor allem um die korruption da
verschwinden eben auch eu gelder einfach
in irgendwelchen dunklen kanälen keiner
kann das nachvollziehen was mit dem geld
passiert das aus der eu kommt und
deshalb hat die kommission jetzt
beschlossen da die daumenschrauben
anzuziehen wo es wirklich wehtut nämlich
bei der kohle genau da tut das wirklich
weh und in dem fall ist es ja auch so
dass es ein ganz direkt zusammenhang
gibt zwischen korruption und einer
drohenden verschwendung der eu gelder
anders als in polen genau gehört da ist
es halt schwieriger zu begründen da hat
man dann gibt es auch bei einwänden die
natürlich nicht ganz von der hand zu
weisen sind dass man jetzt versucht mit
dem mittel des geldhahns die polen dazu
zu bringen in der justizpolitik ihren
kurs wieder zu korrigieren das haben wir
hier auch schon mehrfach besprochen und
da sozusagen muss man so eine brücke
weiter doch nutzen ja und sagen na ja
wenn die justiz nicht mehr unabhängig
ist kann man eben auch nicht davon
ausgehen dass die über die verwendung
der gelder dann ordentlich schaut und
das überwacht und kontrolliert und so
das ist aber natürlich schwieriger zu
begründen und der verdacht drängt sich
da natürlich auf den von den gegnern
also insbesondere aus den von den
gegnern des verfahrens also in polen ein
gewand wird dass es doch reichlich
vorgeschoben sein weil man eigentlich
strafzahlung dafür verlangt dass sich
polen eben nicht an die werte der eu
hält in ungarn wird es einfacher werden
und wie gesagt der europäische
gerichtshof hat den rechtsstaats
mechanismus durchgewunken von daher
können da jetzt polen und ungarn meckern
helfen wird ihn das erst mal nichts wir
schauen mal wann es dann wirklich dazu
kommt dass die eu gelder gekürzt werden
wir bleiben dran
und jetzt kommen wir zu einem gerechten
urteil das vermutlich das einzige ist
was heute in dieser folge nicht ganz so
düster ist wie die restlichen themen die
wir besprochen haben helene du hast du
schon gesagt es geht ums oktoberfest und
es geht um eine eventagentur die
angeboten hat ticket für das oktoberfest
in bestimmten zelten zu ende man denken
wie kann man das denn verbieten den
jetzigen es geht um das oktoberfest 20
22 also wer jetzt meint ich sicher mir
schon mal ein ticket das oktoberfest ist
zweimal ausgefallen 2092 bin ich auf
jeden fall dabei der ist auf dieser
website gekommen hat versucht sich ein
ticket zu sichern
genau also wer da noch nie war es gibt
da ja auf dem oktoberfest großes große
kirmes quasi es gibt aber eben auch
diese zelte in denen man dann sitzen
kann immer so für ein paar stunden da
gibt es auch sehr teure zelte und also
ich weiß nicht ob du schon mal da war
sie däne ich war schon zweimal da für
eine nordrhein westfalen insgesamt eine
suspekte veranstaltung aber das ist für
viele menschen ja wirklich ein
jährlicher termin wo man zwingend hin
muss 2022 gibt es ein kleines problem es
ist nämlich noch gar nicht klar ob das
oktoberfest stattfindet erstmals war das
um klagen der pandemie und dann ist es
jetzt weiterhin unklar wegen des ukraine
krieges das soll wohl erst im mai
entschieden werden das hat aber eine
event-agentur überhaupt nicht
interessiert die hat trotzdem
tischreservierungen in diesen zeiten
vertrieben über eine webseite und
dagegen haben jetzt geklagt drei
münchner gastronomie betriebe die auch
auf dem oktoberfest jeweils ein festzelt
betreiben und die haben gesagt liebe
leute es keine wohl nicht wahr sein dass
die tischreservierungen verkaufen in
unseren zelten obwohl noch nicht mal
klar ist ob das oktoberfest überhaupt
stattfindet die haben wahrscheinlich
angst vor schadensersatzklagen dann oder
was weil sie dann die tische gar nicht
anbieten können wenn die leute mit ihren
karten kommen vermutlich also ich kann
halt schlechten tisch anbieten wenn es
das oktoberfest nicht gibt die
event-agentur card gesagt naja moment
mal auf der webseite wo man diese
tischreservierungen kaufen kann das
steht doch aber es handelt sich um einen
verbindlichen options- erwerb das
landgericht münchen hat gesagt netter
versuch
das ist klar eine irreführung von
verbraucherinnen und verbrauchern und
damit ein verstoß gegen das gesetz gegen
den unlauteren wettbewerb
denn gerade der begriff endlich
suggeriert dass die kunden und kunden da
wirklich und endgültig ein ticket kaufen
könnten und vor allem die möglichkeit
dass man auch noch dieses ticket per
expressversand bestellen konnte sagt das
lg münchen 1 würde doch auch dafür
sprechen dass es da schon wirklich ein
reales und auch ernsthaft verfügbares
ticket gibt dass man das kauft und nicht
das dafür dass verbraucherinnen und
verbraucher erkennen könnten dass diese
tickets überhaupt noch nicht zur
verfügung stehen weil einfach nicht klar
ist ob das oktoberfest stattfinden wird
also expressversand klingt wirklich sehr
nach sicheren die sofort dieses ticket
das ist dir sofort zu kommen sonst
schnappte sich ein anderer weg weil dann
die zeit und das ist glaube ich auch
wirklich so schnell ausverkauft sind ich
habe schon mehrfach auf dem oktoberfest
aus wie soll ich sagen familiären
gründen weil ich bewundere ich jetzt
dass du als kölnerin da so
schwierigkeiten hast ich habe jetzt so
vor eine große freundin
des kölner karnevals als auch das
oktoberfest und kommen ja aus hamburg
also mir ist eigentlich von haus aus
beides ist eigentlich ziemlich fremd ja
aber ich hab dann könnte es noch eine
chance gibt ehrlich gesagt kann man ja
schon sehr schöne stunden verbringen ich
habe ja auch längere zeit in köln
gewohnt und mir war wirklich der
karneval am anfang auch sehr suspekt und
dann habe ich ihn sehr in mein herz
geschlossen und muss sich halt drauf
einlassen das geht auch beim oktoberfest
genau also ich sag das jetzt nix ich bin
gebürtige westfälin vielleicht
beantwortet hast deine frage und da kann
man dann noch so lange in köln leben das
wird irgendwie mir glaube ich nicht
weniger respekt werden dauerhaft wieder
der karneval noch das oktoberfest
trotzdem natürlich total gerechtes
urteil man kann ja nichts verkaufen das
ist noch gar nicht gibt wo kommen wir
denn da hin sozusagen also ob man es nun
mag oder nicht ist jetzt völlig
zweitrangig ist nicht okay
tickets zu verkaufen die ja sehr teuer
sind für zelte dies dann vielleicht gar
nicht gibt insofern sehr gerecht vom
münchner landgericht und vor dem
oktoberfest kommt noch ostern und da
machen wir eine pause eine zweiwöchige
pause exakt wir hören uns wieder am 27
04 in alter frische freuen uns natürlich
aber trotzdem über post von höhere und
hören wie immer an einspruch podcast
faz.de das muss ich dieses mal
ausnahmsweise sagen normalerweise sagt
das kokain war so wunderschön ich musste
natürlich jetzt noch mal kurz nachgucken
einspruch podcast faz.de ihr leben da
draußen
trotz dieser unfassbar grauen vorzeiten
wir wünschen euch eine gute woche wir
wünschen euch drei gute wochen wir hören
uns wieder am 27 04 und freuen uns schon
darauf und ich bin anfang mai dann
wieder dabei hier ich freue mich jetzt
schon drauf alles gute bis dahin
bleiben sie bleibt alle gesund und so
munter wie es irgendwie geht
[Musik]